you are Canadian I am birth you're a US
citizen is now the why from that I
became citizens in 2000 so this year we
we celebrated Thanksgiving the
traditional way we flew to Vancouver
yeah as the pilgrims did right well as
people people given others they they we
have Thanksgiving do you in Canada why
would you have for that that's that the
Americans always have the same response
which is you do that is so cute you guys
with your little Thanksgiving you know
but when I tell them that it's in fact
30 years before the pilgrims Canada was
celebrating this it was a harvest
celebration they don't like that
Americans don't like to hear that we
know we like to think Thanksgiving is
our thing exactly right you know you
Canadians have your own stuff we hope
you hear wool hats and your cereal you
know don't don't be Horning in on our
Thanksgiving I'm telling you we were
there first and that when I tell people
they they love this when I tell people I
don't put marshmallows in food and I
don't watch football then it's like
homeland security comes to the door they
get down so you tweeted about this you
tweeted I think you sent out a tweet
wishing everyone a Happy Thanksgiving
and you said despite the whole
marshmallows and yams thing you made it
clear you don't believe in marshmallows
well let me tell ya in this country that
is a very dangerous tweet yeah no I mean
tweeting people got mad people got mad
it was like I was tweeting about Hillary
again there's nothing you know it was
like don't say marshmallows and unless
you're gonna include yams yeah can't do
it so you don't believe in that whole
thing I can't I got them right so you
did celebrate a traditional Thanksgiving
you know what we actually did in fact
Canadians do it quite traditionally we
just do it a month early we're just
we're that eager this is the reason I
bring it up is because in Europe they
always say they have our holidays but I
listen to them and they just sound lame
compared like when you hear about a and
I know this is being seen in other
countries and apologies ahead of time
but but current things you're laying now
but like in Belgium they'll say like yes
we celebrate Christmas and I'll be like
yeah do you have big trees and presents
no we give each other a walnut
yes Holland you know Holland and and
there's Santa Claus whoo yeah there are
Santa Claus I get to be the Archduke of
something and Sedaris is like let me
tell you something
Santa didn't used to be anyone yeah yeah
it's just a drag they just take all the
fun out of it we know how to do it right
which is hundreds of thousands of
dollars worth in kiss made from
petroleum products jammed under a tree
that are soon forgotten
gasps Christmas absolutely right that's
what it's all about hopefully a tree you
can you can put together yourself yes I
have an inflatable tree nice
you